hisoka is back this is such a surreal
moment for the entire succession warrock
thus far the idea of hisoka actually
being involved was like more of a legend
and in fact the last time we saw our
favorite vigorous battle clown was way
back in 2016. so we've had around eight
years of hisokalis existence it was a
very empty time but hisoka is here to
fill us all back up as well as
potentially fill himself up because what
is with that tracksuit with the heart
and the arrow pointing directly at his
butt and everything and of hisoka what
you doing but I think what I love most
about this whole situation is the
completely anti-glimactic way that
hisoka was found like he was literally
the second guy we checked and after all
of the all right everyone we need to
find hisoka he could be anywhere
disguised as anyone and it's going to
take all of us working together trying
our hardest to find all of the clues to
no wait he's right over there it's such
a classic Togashi anti-climax which
works really well for Hunter Hunter
because it makes the world feel more
realistic and I also think that this was
very necessary in context of the Hiatus
the last chapter our first chapter back
was a bit confusing for a lot of people
they just jumped straight back into hunt
Hunter and it was like reading a whole
different series with all of these
characters unfamiliar characters so I do
think it was very important to get our
bearings back here by injecting the
chapter with a solid shot of hunter
hunter that is hisoka I mean the thing
is we are already in an arc featuring
primarily new characters the only real
familiar protagonist we've had is
karapik I mean yes leoria was here but
it's not like we're spending any time
with him so reintroducing hisoka feels
like we finally have a core element of
the series back however I should say
that this probably all but kills the
illumines hisoker idea that I enjoyed so
much and that's not a bad thing as far
as I'm concerned the only important
thing is that we have hisoka however as
my last gasp of copium I will say two
things thing number one we never got
Lynch's answer she asked the question
and she did a punch but we never got the
actual confirmation of what the truth is
and also number two countering someone
instinctively like that is in some very
assassin-like thing to do so maybe
there's no incredibly convoluted
scenario where ilami is impersonating
hisoka whilst hisoka is impersonating
illumin because they're both completely
capable of doppelganging one another
illumi has even done that with hisoka
before and they have almost precisely
the same height but until further
Evidence comes into things I'm gonna let
go of that crazy conspiracy idea because
I am just so damn happy to have my
beloved murder clown back my favorite
panel was of course that wonderful smirk
given to zakra which is just um classic
hisoka he doesn't need to project his
Aura in any way to be intimidating all
he has to do is smile at you because
when hisoker is smiling that means that
something very very unpleasant is likely
to happen in general I love the look
he's going for we almost never get to
see like the hair down and make up Lucy
Soca he kind of just looks like a
regular dude until he turns around and
you see that that heart pointing
straight up his ass like kizoka is
trying to be stealthy and blend in but
he's not trying that hard and really the
whole thing just hit me with a wave of
nostalgia the succession war is still
such an unfamiliar environment and toned
for Hunter Hunter so it's bizarre highly
comforting to have this familiar element
back I say bizarrely because again
having hisoker around generally means
that the bad things are about to happen
I also really love Lynch's blunt
strategy for finding him you know the
whole we're just gonna punch everyone
over a sudden height until we Maybe
Might maybe find hisoka so I gobbled
that up but I actually think that's a
great representation of Lynch's strategy
maybe it'll get done if I just keep
punching people and especially when
Henry said once you find hisoka don't do
anything until I get there but to find
hisoka Lynch has to do something and now
she's lying unconscious on the floor I
wonder if they're gonna leave her there
what this chapter has cleared up is why
the Chara and xiu families were tracking
down hisoka to begin with it's been a
very common thought that they also
wanted to kill him to prevent future
troop based Anarchy but they also
flagged in the last chapter that could
be the complete opposite and that's
turned out to be the case the Chara and
xiu families want to enable hisoka to
kill murder The Troop however as always
it's a bit more complicated than that
because at the very least Wang also
wants to use the troop to destroy the
hell Leaf Family if possible Wang is the
Chara underboss by the way a name I
remember because Wang means penis but
this chapter excels at one of togashi's
finest features as writer which is
creating a focal point of chaos he is a
master of crafting those Flashpoint
style situations where the outcome is
impossible to predict because there are
just too many variables in play so we've
got all of these characters doing the
plannings and the schemings but also
very ready to improvise because things
could go in any direction at any second
in all of those directions are probably
bad on the GU side of things Henry had a
fascinating scene in this chapter with
another classic tagashi feature of just
heading wildly unnecessary detail it's
something that I really have come to
love but when Henry was talking to the
soldier dude he was just going on and on
and on about why his information was
trustworthy I was just like yeah any
other writer would probably not do this
they'd come up with like a clever
one-line done and dusted reason but it's
fascinating to read because it gives us
an insight into how Togashi thinks in
that sort of excruciating realistic
detail and again it makes the world feel
very very deep and very real something I
was not expecting was a surprise new
nanability and not from Henry in fact
not not from anyone currently aboard the
black whale 1 or indeed aboard the Good
Ship of Life a new post-mortem
nanability with the interesting subtitle
of La Vie En Rose which means life in
pink or basically looking at life with
rose-colored glasses Lavi and Rose is
also very famously a song titled by
Edith pilaf one of history's most
prolific singers if you're not familiar
it was also one of her songs that
featured an Inception as the wake-up
call that one was no regrets for such a
morbid ability though especially with
the corpse where it's all like it's it's
incredibly positive for such a
disturbing ability because when you get
down to it yes it's a corpse disposal
power a post-mortem nanbeast is either
conjured or omitted and then it
manipulates the body to be disposed of
very useful but it does make me wonder
what kind of person the original user
was because generally I think that we
have a tendency to associate post-mortem
nen with feelings of Anguish and grudges
and all of the bad things like that but
now then responds to all emotion and I
imagine that in this case the user left
this Legacy because they were so
overwhelmingly positive looking at life
through rose-colored glasses or in this
case much more optimistically looking at
death through rose-colored glasses the
user was probably someone who treasured
what they had which was the GU family so
in death that overwhelming feeling has
persisted it's a really cool ability and
I like that Togashi is continuing to
explore this more unknown world of Nan
and on a much more mundane level as well
like post-mortem Nan isn't always some
bra Grand Act of power sometimes it's
just an average person leaving their
small mark on this insanely gigantic
world I also do quite like that Henry
spent about 10 minutes on his mission
before he inevitably gets called back by
zakura because they found hisoka so
quickly again the second guy they
checked and it makes me very keen for a
scene between these two because they
have that whole magician Mystique in
common but with this chapter we also cut
back to focusing on the chart our family
a bit more and in particular
he has a great scene if you don't
remember he was the one major really
fanboying about the Phantom troop when
feitan thinks Nobunaga stepped into
their territory and here he has this
hilarious bit about trying to buy some
shikishi which is like you know classic
japanese autograph paper but it also
leads to something which could either be
a very big something or a complete
nothing you know the whole logistical
explanation of how people can order
things from the human realm to be
delivered to the black whale 1 via
planes and drones that is either going
to be a very very relevant plot point or
it's going to be Togashi just
overthinking things again going down the
spiral of logistics you know like you
did back in the day with that whole
chapter about explaining the various
types of auctions in York new city as
mentioned before underboss Wang gets
some nice time in 392. very correctly
deducing that they have no hope of
really manipulating the Phantom troop to
suit their causes and again correctly he
also deduces that the troop are only
going to cause more trouble by robbing
Tier 1 after this whole hisoka business
is done but it's really nice to see The
Troop receiving this kind of respect
from the mafia underworld because I
think it's often easy to forget that the
Phantom troop are in a whole League of
Their Own when it comes to nen users in
the series I think it's because we went
from just learning that nen exists to
immediately meeting the troop and it was
only afterwards that we got to
experience these like more middling
levels of men but also during your new
city there was a distinct impression of
the troop were always underestimated
like that whole disaster with the 10
Dawns and the shadow beasts but here we
get to see the notoriety in veteranosity
being played out in real time not so
much because of their power just yet but
because of their display of experience
there is a very Stark line of contrast
drawn between the troop and luini in
this chapter luini has done quite
possibly the worst thing he could have
with his ability by launching
essentially a head-on assault against
three troop members and not only is he
completely unaware of their abilities
but he is also admitted to completely
misjudging them in terms of personality
so basically lewinia is jumping into
fight battling here and working off
nothing I mean at the very least if he
knew what kind of people they were he
might have some chance of predicting
their net abilities or at the very least
how they might use nen abilities at
least that's what experience their users
would do which we do also see here
because despite their astronomical power
vinx fatan and obanagar are quite
content to sit and calmly wait maybe
read a magazine and in fact they even
discuss further consolidation strategies
like bring in Franklin and dividing into
pairs even though they are potentially
the most powerful people on the ship
they know that they need to be careful
because all it takes is one weird Nan
interaction and that is the death which
I imagine was only further nailed into
them as a result of overkine now with
that said I am unbelievably excited by
the end of this chapter because it
promises something we've been waiting
for for far far too long which is the
potential of finally seeing banolanov's
nen abilities there are very few Phantom
troop members whose powers are
completely unknown in fact thinking
about it I'm pretty sure that banolanov
is the only one all we know is that
banolanov is an enhancer and I should
say that we only know that because of
the hunt Hunter data book which is not
historically being in the most accurate
source of information in the past so
while I do think it's likely that he's
an enhancer this could go in any
direction I also imagine that banolanov
is completely overpowered in small
confined spaces like say the small
confined room that we're currently in so
luini in the situation really is like a
mouse trying to taunt a lion he just has
no idea what he's stepping into because
he's only been an end user for a handful
of days maybe a week at most and like
his other healthy family members that we
saw in 391 he's just completely arrogant
and drunk on all of the Newfound power
he's acquired but considering that each
of the Phantom troop have had absolutely
ridiculous abilities like Conjuring
Jupiter or even transmuting a miniature
Sun I really cannot wait to see what
Nobunaga brings to the table here it
might not be as big and flashy as the
others in fact you could practically
guarantee it doesn't but I can also
practically guarantee that it will still
be just as overpowered and then then
things can get really moving because the
reason why these three are still on tier
5 is because they agreed to kill the
Haley assassin AKA luini and luini has
gone and made their job far far easier
for them than it should have been but
after that the troop can stop moving
meanwhile the all-out mafia walk and
begin and the entirety of the lower
decks can be destabilized just as Tier 1
currently is right now the best way
place to be is probably on tier two that
is currently the only Deck with no
problems whatsoever but we are seriously
ramping things up at quite an alarming
rate here bringing mizai's Dom's fear of
complete destruction one step closer to
reality we are two chapters in and
already so much has happened and I
cannot wait for more